Alyce's with us in canada hi Alice how
are you hi good how are those of you
great talking dr. John and me help um I
think you're the perfect ones to help me
um so I was in a difficult marriage for
a long time and it was especially hard
to leave because I didn't have access to
the funds in the marriage so finally I
got myself out and over years I rebuilt
my finances and established freedom
financially and now I'm in a
relationship and have been for years and
we're talking about marriage and now I'm
in the position where I make a lot more
money and I do believe as you do that
sharing finances is important but it
kind of scares me to potentially lose
control again if that makes any sense
yeah I mean what you would say makes a
lot of sense so what are you making what
you make I make about 650 and makes
about 150 what do you do
650 god oh wow
so impressive good for you you said
that's so casually okay I make a little
bit more than him and then you just boom
yeah so that's amazing congratulations
okay 50 well I do not recommend
prenuptial agreements except in
situations where the the differences are
extreme and the differences here are
extreme okay and so I would recommend a
prenuptial agreement another example
would be I was coaching talking to a
young lady who had inherited eight
million dollars and she's marrying her
highschool boyfriend who had never had
eight dollars and nothing wrong with the
marriage you can go ahead and do that
but but yeah because what happens is
this the money in there in your case
it's income or her case there's a pile
of money does not necessarily make you
weird or your husband weird but
somewhere in one of your family's weird
is going to be exaggerated because of
this and it's going to influence
an impact and if you've got the shield
of a prenup it sets the boundaries a
little more firmly and I I do recommend
that to help you with that I'll tell you
what can you hopefully the break I want
John to speak to this as well because
he's probably got something a lot wiser
to say than me giving you a tactical
thing so cuz there's you know there's
emotions tied to this too
that we need to address so hang with me
through the break we're talking with
alice in canada $650,000 income her
boyfriend potential husband makes 150
she's concerned about the differences i
was i said going into the break that
because the differences are so great she
might want to consider a prenup because
that amount of money activates crazy up
and down the family tree like nothing
else does and it's good to have that in
place I don't recommend a prenup any
other time but I do in rare
circumstances and this is this is one of
them so but how Alex you're back with us
is that a fair summary of what you told
us so far yeah I think I realize though
a lot of it is concerned in me that
isn't necessarily valid so and I think
it relates to my past experience I don't
know if it's reasonable so yeah let me
tell you this any one of these feelings
based on past experiences is not only
valid it's important that you listen to
that your past history your past
experiences and they inform your steps
going forward you just expressed one of
the the biggest challenges that women
face in broken relationships is that
that economic insecurity and so you've
man you you ground it out and now you
are making most of the known world
jealous with the success you've had
financially but that demon that that
fear you're gonna have that's gonna be
with you for a long time and so the
challenge you're gonna have coming to
this new marriage is to a both honor
your past and learn from those those
experiences set up set up ways where
you're going to be safe moving forward
and at the same time don't force your
new husband your new partner to carry
that baggage because that's not his to
carry with you right his is to join with
you and your new adventure that y'all
are making together so man your your
past experiences are super valid super
valid those fears are real real real
don't make him carry that back for you
right yeah that's so set in place what
you would consider what will be
emotionally uncomfortable the sharing of
money as long as there's a a normal
healthy relationship going and you share
of course when you're when you're
married you know for richer for poorer
in sickness and health unto thee all my
worldly goods I pledge the old-fashioned
marriage marriage vows say and so you
know what we're doing is we're joining
in so many ways we're joining households
were joining in spirit we're joining
we're becoming one and you want to do
that with your money as well that's
going to be decidedly uncomfortable for
you and he needs to know that and he
needs to honor the fact that you're
gonna be uncomfortable doing that and he
can't give you any reason he's got to be
very hyper attentive to not give you any
reason to become more uncomfortable
Alice are you weirded out that you make
more money to him I'm not he's not and I
think he even leaned toward oh if you're
uncomfortable then we don't have to
combined but I think that feels no you
know I think it's it's you know he just
says hey my wife has a valid scar a
wound a tender place and I've got to
honor that in the way that we do combine
that and and you just got to talk about
it more I'll give you another give you
an example in my life that's that's
similar and yet not okay Sharon and I
lost everything with a brand-new baby a
toddler we almost killed each other we
came within an inch of a divorce okay
mm-hmm can you imagine after that with
that scar in our past almost 30 years
ago how important the emergency fund is
to her to a woman who was terrorized
by her husband's idiocy with money right
great so you know and and so she's got
that scar so I have to honor that wound
that I actually caused okay but I have
to honor that wound by having an
emergency fund for the emergency fund
we don't even walk near the drawer where
the paperwork is kept it's on the other
end of the house you're not allowed to
go on that into the house I mean it's
like this thing it means so much more
emotionally and relationally than simply
a little bit of money in an account in
case there's an emergency because I'm
honoring that wound albeit a very old
wound now but still if you ask her today
she can get she can remember it or
throat gets tight you can see her eyes
change a cloud comes across them and you
know so we just can't I can't do things
that remind her of that because she
starts to think we're gonna go back
there again right and so that's the kind
of thing I'm talking about here is you
look you look for some practical way to
do that and I would do a prenup which
will also give you some comfort but it
will not heal this what heals this is
you guys you might even really get some
real detailed in-depth pre-marriage
counseling and kind of plot out map out
some of this stuff on how you're gonna
work together mm-hmm it's a great
question yeah it's lovely in Alice work
so Dave you mind if I use your and
Sharon situation I have had it so we're
often this plays out in it beacon that
responds to that scar can can make
injuries across the house is let's take
Sharon for instance she may feel like
this emergency fund isn't where it needs
to be we had to get into the emergency
fund to the emergency fund but that
comes out with Oh Dave you're just going
out with the boys again or oh I guess I
have to cook again it ends up coming out
in different places when really it's a
it's an honest conversation we need to
have about the money part and so I think
what's real important for you and your
future husband to do is to identify
moments when it's not the fact that he
was late getting home it's not the fact
that we hit on the insurance paperwork
yet it's the fact that that scar hurts
and you need to be
able to articulate that and be direct
with him about that so that it doesn't
shoot out in other areas he distracts
you from the real issue which is
historical pain that's real Wow thanks
good and congrats to you Alice yeah and
by the way let me just tell you my
number one cause of divorce in America
today y'all listening is money and money
fights right so let's pretend you got
one of those divorces it's number one
cause and then you get ready to get
remarried you're having the exact same
thing she's dealing with right and it's
a scale issue having eight hundred
thousand dollars doesn't make that
problem no way we say it makes it it
makes it magnify it's exactly doesn't
make it go away and so I mean it doesn't
matter you know if your husband your
wife whatever my wife I've had people
calling my wife was a spender she spent
us into oblivion and now I'm scared the
new lady's gonna do that well you can't
make her carry her bags right right what
you said but you said I'd talk to her
about but on the other hand you know
she's got to understand that you walk
with a limp over here because of that
other thing yes and you know that that's
that's part of the package
you're getting so because you're either
gonna marry someone that's the polar
opposite of the crap you left or you're
gonna do the same stupid thing again
right right is usually what happens and
so Larry Burkett used to say people run
up a bunch of debt and then get divorced
because of the debt and they remarry and
then they run up a bunch of more debt
because they didn't change anything they
marry someone looks just like the other
one hmm and I'd do it again and so you
got it there has to be a break in the
cycle because money money is not the
problem it's it reveals the other
problems and that's really good stuff
Alice it's really good stuff I
appreciate you hanging through the break
with us and then you know so the other
in the spectrum now we had a guy I think
I mentioned it last week I can't
remember which one of the personalities
were co-hosting with me but I had a lady
call in one day said my husband wants a
fiance wants a prenup mm that's really
what's he see god there's a sports car
nope I said uh he's not gonna really be
your husband all right this guy loves
his car more he loves you hmm if he if
he has to protect his car from you he
I ain't the one you know so that's the
other end of the spectrum on this
because everybody thinks the prenups
gonna solve everything and it doesn't
right it doesn't and cuz you see all
this in the tabloids with the Hollywood
types and all these guys you know the
music types or whatever led a prenup and
you know I'm easily against him I don't
like family of starting a relationship
with the foot out the door right I don't
I don't want to land the death while I'm
alive anything so that's I'm totally
against them but in extreme situations
it helps keep the crazy family members
at bay and it settles down the nerve so
you can deal with the actuals that you
wait are you